vamos a resolver algunos ejemplos más de
algunas ecuaciones que tengan en qué
presiones racionales vamos a resolver x
más 1 entre x y esto vamos a hacerlo
igual vamos a hacerlo igual a 2 entonces
una vez más aquí tenemos una equis en el
denominador verdad lo cual es un poco
extraño pero simplemente hay que
recordar que si multiplicamos cada
término por este denominador entonces
cuando hagamos la multiplicación aquí en
medio en este de aquí se va a cancelar
con el denominador va a ser x por 1
entre x y se va a convertir en un 1
entonces vamos a hacer esto vamos a
multiplicar cada uno de estos términos
por x multiplicamos aquí por x
multiplicamos por aquí por x y en la
derecha también multiplicamos por x
entonces estamos multiplicando a ambos
lados de la ecuación por el denominador
del medio y entonces tenemos un x por x
que ese x cuadrada aquí hay que sumarle
x por 1 entre x lo cual es simplemente
un 1 x se cancela con el x y eso de aquí
queremos que sea igual a 2 por x
entonces 2 por x 2 x
y estoy aquí ya se empieza a parecer un
poco más a una ecuación cuadrática
tenemos que restar 2x verdad de los dos
lados para que está igualada 0 entonces
si hacemos eso vamos a restar 2x a la
izquierda vamos a restar 2x a la derecha
y entonces que obtenemos en la izquierda
en la izquierda de nuestra ecuación
tenemos una x cuadrada menos 2 x más 1 y
del lado derecho justo se cancela el 2x
y nos queda 0 entonces ahora si ya es
una de cuadra en ecuación cuadrática que
sabemos cómo resolver podemos factorizar
o usar la fórmula cuadrática pero se ve
fácil de factorizar porque menos 1 x
menos 1 es uno menos uno más menos uno
es menos dos y entonces podemos
factorizar lo como x menos uno por x
menos uno y eso de allí tiene que ser
igual a cero ahora sí tenemos un
producto de dos números que dan cero
cuando los multiplicamos entonces uno de
ellos o los dos tienen que ser iguales a
cero aquí pues tenemos el mismo número
verdad es x menos uno
al cuadrado y eso de aquí tiene que ser
igual a cero entonces de que x menos 1
al cuadrado sea igual a 0 podemos decir
que x menos 1 es igual a 0 sumando uno
de ambos lados una izquierda obtenemos x
y en la derecha obtenemos 1 y con esto
tenemos nuestro resultado pero pues
vamos a ver si funciona vamos a poner
este 1 acá arriba nos queda un 1 más 1
entre 1 eso nos debería dar 2 y en
efecto nos da igual a 2 entonces esto
funcionó y así este ejemplo que estaba
un poco fácil lo pudimos resolver pero
ya que calentamos motores vamos a pasar
un ejemplo más difícil pongamos dos
entre y vamos a poner es una expresión
más complicada vamos a poner x cuadrada
más 4 x más 3 y
supongamos que estoy aquí es igual a 2
más 2 más y vamos a ponerle este lado x
2 entre x 3 recordemos que lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar el valor de
x y justo como lo hicimos en el ejemplo
anterior queremos quitar las x del
denominador la mejor forma de hacerlo es
multiplicar cada cosa cada cosa por pues
como el mínimo común múltiplo de los
denominadores para no hacer tanto
trabajo verdad entonces la primera cosa
que queremos hacer es factorizar el
denominador de la izquierda para ver si
tiene términos en común con el de la
derecha entonces qué números al
multiplicar nos dan 3 y al sumarlos dan
4 pues 3 y 1 verdad entonces esta cosa
de acá lo voy a reescribir como x x + 3
por x x + 3 ching ahora que me doy
cuenta aquí a la derecha tengo que
ponerle más en realidad copian mal el
problema entonces bueno siguiendo con la
izquierda es x + 3 x x + 1
entonces qué podemos hacer para eliminar
los denominadores porque cosa tenemos
que multiplicar para eliminarlos
queremos cancelar el x3 el x + 1
entonces basta multiplicar todo por x 3
y luego por x 1 entonces esto de acá la
expresión de la izquierda es divisible
entre el x + 3 entonces el mínimo común
múltiplo de x más 3 x 3 por x + 1 es x
cuadrada más 4 x 3 verdad entonces bueno
vamos a multiplicar cada uno de los
lados por esta expresión x más 3 x x + 1
entonces tenemos lo voy a poner con con
morado x + 3 x x + 1 x
por 1 2 / / x 3 x x 1
y eso de ahí es igual a voy a regresar
al morado x 3 x x + 1 y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por el 2 que está aquí lo
voy a poner por acá es por 2 verdad y
ahí hay que sumarle hay que sumarle otra
vez debemos seguir multiplicando por x +
3 por x + 1 y hay que multiplicarlo por
este término que nos falta que es un x2
dividido entre x + 3 entonces lo que
hicimos es lo que hicimos es multiplicar
por x más 3 por x + 1 paquete para que
se cancelara entonces del lado izquierdo
nos queda un 2 y eso va a ser igual a
dos veces esta expresión esta expresión
ya la tenemos verdad en realidad esto de
aquí viene del primer término que es x
cuadrada más 4 x + 3 porque justo así la
factory samos entonces es dos veces esta
expresión tenemos que multiplicar dos
por cada término es 2
bueno déjenme usar verde entonces este
término es 2 por equis cuadrada que da 2
x cuadrada de ahí tenemos que sumar 2
por 4 x es 18 x y luego hay que sumar 2
x 3 que es 2006 verdad
y ahora este término de acá que es x 3
se cancela con el denominador de aquí
abajo si se cancela con el de acá con
este x + 3 y entonces simplemente nos
queda un x + 1 x 1 x 2 y bueno vamos a
hacer esta operación lo voy a hacer aquí
abajo lo voy a lo voy a marcar aquí
estoy aquí queda un poco feo voy a
volver a dibujar el rectángulo
para marcar lo que va en morado entonces
esa multiplicación da tenemos que hacer
x por x que es x cuadrada luego tenemos
que hacer x x menos 2 que es menos 2 x
luego hay que hacer un 1 por x entonces
sumamos un x por acá y luego el 1 x
menos 2 a es un -2 y ahora hay que hacer
la suma vamos a simplificar un poco a la
izquierda se queda simplemente un 2 y
eso es igual entonces vamos a juntar
términos iguales a ver que tiene x
cuadrada estos dos de aquí tienen x
cuadrada nos queda tres veces x cuadrada
entonces vámonos ahora con los términos
que tienen x con los términos lineales
18 x 1 - 2x y 1 x entonces pues que pasa
ese 8 x 2 x mas x aquí y aquí a la
derecha es un menos x nada más entonces
cuando eso lo sumamos con el 8 x nos
queda más 7x y nos faltan los términos
libres los números verdad entonces hay
que este 6 voy a voy a cambiar de color
puede utilizar rosa entonces aquí voy a
poner un 6 ponemos el menos 2 y cuando
los juntamos nos quedan más 4
y entonces pues nos falta restar dos de
ambos lados de la ecuación para tener la
igualada cero verdad entonces restamos
dos de ambos lados y vamos a ver que nos
quedan nos queda cero a la izquierda y
eso es igual a 3x cuadrada más 7x y aquí
estamos quitando 2 del 4 entonces voy a
ponerle más 2 y ahora sí tenemos una
ecuación cuadrática o sea fíjense la
expresión inicial que teníamos la cual
tenía sus dificultades la logramos
transformar por medio de un poco de
álgebra en una expresión cuadrática
estándar que ya sabemos resolver muy
bien recordemos que tenemos varios
métodos para encontrar las soluciones de
una ecuación cuadrática una opción es
factorizar pero aquí el término cuadrado
no es igual a uno y entonces esto puede
ser un poco latoso entonces vayamos a la
segura y usemos la fórmula general para
resolver ecuaciones de segundo grado
entonces x es igual a menos 7 más menos
y hay que sacar la raíz de b cuadrada
que es 7 al cuadrado que es 49 menos 4
veces a que son 3 x c que es un 2 y todo
eso lo tenemos que dividir entre 2 veces
a dos veces a es 2 por 3 entonces lo
ponemos aquí 6
esto de aquí pues a ver vamos a
simplificar un poquito 4 por 3 12 por 23
24 esto de aquí es 24
49 24 25 parece ser que vamos bien
porque eso sí tiene raíz déjenme ponerle
un poquito más abajo para no hacer esto
es así como mucho arriba y arriba
entonces x es igual a menos 7 más menos
la raíz
de 49 24 entonces vimos que era 25
ponemos ahí el 25 y hay que dividir
entre 6 entonces tenemos que considerar
dos casos ahorita podemos menos 7 más
menos 5 lo dividimos entre 6 y hay dos
opciones si sumamos 5 vamos a tener
menos 7 5 que es menos 12 entre 6 da
menos un tercio esa es la primera
solución y la otra opción es que
tengamos menos 7 menos 5 y eso de ahí es
un -12 dividido entre un 6 es igual a
menos 2 y entonces el menos un tercio
menos 2 son las dos soluciones al
ejercicio que teníamos planteado con un
poco de álgebra llegamos a una ecuación
cuadrática que ya sabíamos cómo resolver
esperamos que te haya gustado